ladies and gentlemen Noah Baumbach
I've never given a lecture before
so since I'm gonna sit and talk about my
own movies for a while in conversation I
thought I'd start by talking a little
bit about other people's movies Mike
Nichols said about directors speculating
on how other directors do their job is
how all the rest of us think about sex
which is does everybody do it this way
I'd also wanted to focus in particular
on the beginnings of certain movies the
opening sequences is sort of you know
the way we're first introduced to the
characters to the story and how you know
directors and writers choose to begin I
think as many filmmakers are in the
audience's you that you know that this
is something we're tasked with inventing
all of the time
my friend Brian DePalma who is also the
subject of a documentary I made
emphasizes that it's your only chance to
introduce the audience to your
characters into your movie this is your
opportunity to do anything you want and
the director must take this
responsibility very seriously he said
you think about how many movies start
with generic aerial shots of the city
why would you blow this opportunity with
drones this has even easier now to do
but then you think about the opening of
The Shining where the aerial shots say
everything those gliding images with
that music
that's strange haunting feeling so of
course there are no rules or when we
make them for ourselves we need to know
when to break them Greta Gerwig pointed
out to me that my movies tend to tell
you what they're about at the very
beginning I wasn't aware of this
but it's embarrassing when you go back
and look mom and me versus you and dad
is the opening line of the squid in the
whale in Greenburgh Greta Gerwig herself
says to the unseen car in the lane next
to her while she's trying to merge are
you going to let me in interestingly
when I was doing press for Greenberg an
interviewer pointed out this line to me
and that it told the whole story of the
movie and of her and Ben Stiller's
characters that the movie was about
letting people in and I started to cry
because I had never thought about it
this way honestly I just thought she was
changing lanes so as filmmakers were
aware of some things and not of others
and I'd like to keep it this way if I
may I find in general that if you're
successful in telling the story the
other things take care of themselves I
pick for movies and beginnings that I
that I love I mean they're movies that I
love but they're also particular or
special to me because of the ways that I
came to them when I first saw them so
we're going to look at a couple of clips
and the first is from Jules and Jim
directed by Francois Truffaut and the
second is from Goodfellas directed by
Martin Scorsese and this is how both
movies open so I'm supposed to make this
very obvious so now we should play the
clips
and Timothy I am Jedidiah Jedidiah palma
de midi vato
[Music]
citavi edition of seduce Julie Foucher
Atari event Medea Jim kickin is a
dependency on Hoebel de casa Jim we have
a pocket elevated national costume a
soprano casual reduce my family set of
this was ready set a sample costume this
club can a kilometers import algún tipo
null values will fit on kill Eric this
you come the bull plan to move at dawn
rise the non-manual of chromium
recommendation is in severe to review
Chicano Sunita lutefisk a turtle and
miscellaneous an idea to you in Sumatra
love poem little visit and some
interpretation Camino relative
indifference of Al Ahram el COSO Otto
Caledonia Ramez Avenue dieter Seattle
teef Univ apart from no savvy per se na
no sweaty twin dreamin of a pleasure
envision contrarian musician
nada be somewhat favorable real free
tomorrow in Seminole you see
precipitous reboot fan disable Keaton el
Kunal a cafe me Oakley poetry's cases
automata not offer sufficient river to
drown lizard sot @ wa la casa de la
cultura version team a mellow
I am Napoleon and Placid Missoula a
placid normal relay video Jim usually
contact led professional massage it to
my satisfaction
Jimmy as far back as I can remember I
always wanted to be a gangster
[Music]
there's a scene in a movie I made cold
while we're young where character played
by Ben Stiller is giving a lecture this
I had to imagine this because I as I
told you I've never given a lecture
before and he's a PowerPoint
presentation and it stops working and he
tries to figure it out and we tried to
get some laughs that way
I now know that experience because the
in in my dream of this moment we would
play through the entire montage at the
beginning of Goodfellas so but there was
some right down in the communication so
you only got that first part that first
part doesn't really relate to Jules and
Jim as much as the part that comes after
but it's probably on YouTube maybe
someone could get it up on their phone
and pass it around and include in it and
maybe you guys remember it Tony Bennett
sings I go from rags to riches and he's
after he says I want to be a gangster we
see him as a kid and it's always great
when people talk movies well I in well
in 1990 I was at Vassar College in
Poughkeepsie New York it's about two
hours outside of New York City if you
don't know Poughkeepsie it's also
immortalized in the French Connection
where he says do you pick your toes and
pick it see I grew up with parents who
loved movies who sometimes wrote about
movies and who introduced me to many
kinds of movies but it wasn't until
college that I began to truly appreciate
international cinema it was at Vassar
that I saw Jules and Jim for the first
time and it's great when you see I
imagine people the audience have had
this feeling hopefully many times but
it's great when you're younger and you
see the right movie at the right time I
felt elated when I saw that movie from
the very beginning of that
montage and it seemed so contemporary to
me the ideas of friendship were very
relatable to me
although the specifics were totally out
of my experience no weirdly the subtitle
of pros PR OS and even the central love
triangle really the main story of the
movie was it was mysterious to me and it
really remains that way to me to this
day but none of that matters because the
movie had such feeling and such energy
and I've returned to it many times over
the years and it's meant different
things to me every time I see it
and if pressed to say my favorite movie
which is always an annoying question
just because I never feel like I'm gonna
do to do it right for myself but I will
often say Jules in gym I'll also say ET
the same week I went to the picket see
Galleria which was a mall 30 minutes
from school where we'd go to see new
movies and I saw the new Martin Scorsese
movie Goodfellas and it blew me out of
my seat and as a teenager in the 1980s I
was discovering a lot of great artists
from the 70s and the 60s and before that
often on VHS that's where I I was told I
should take a moment to explain what VHS
before it came out of the sky you had to
put tapes and things to play things you
could record on them you could record
for six hours but the quality was
terrible my my parents got divorced my
father was seeing dating a woman who
lived in Manhattan which was very
glamorous for all of us and for many
reasons but in Manhattan they had cable
again for those of you before it came
out of the sky
it came from under the earth but in
Brooklyn we had no cable they didn't
give us cable now Brooklyn is everything
everyone loves Brooke but then there was
they they we weren't worthy of cable so
she would record things on these
six-hour extended play tapes and through
just she just run it on Showtime on it
and my father would bring them back and
we'd be so excited and we would get
things I actually put this in the
meyerwitz story as a version of this but
we would get things like gorillas in the
mist
scanners you know Beverly Hills Cop they
were just it so we would have these sort
of triple shows that made no sense
except it was just what they ran on on
the thing that's a digression but often
these filmmakers that I was discovering
from the past when I would see their new
movies or things you know that they were
coming out currently in the in the movie
theater it sometimes wasn't considered
their best and I always felt like oh I
was born too late i i I'm not getting
the best moment of this stuff you know
I'm you know my bond was Roger Moore my
Rolling Stones was the album dirty work
which I doesn't get much of a laugh
because nobody knows what I'm talking
but here in Poughkeepsie I was seeing a
classic in real time my Scorsese was
Goodfellas and in Poughkeepsie I felt
like Truffaut and Scorsese were speaking
to each other in some way because if
you'd seen the rest of the clip this
would make a lot more sense but so
because the he tells the story similarly
and the rest of the clip in that it's
but it's with Henry Hills voiceover
instead of this sort of omniscient
narrator of Jules and Jim and it has it
tells you very deliberately what is
going on and I would just like to add as
a matter of fact checking that when I
moderated Martin Scorsese's DGA
screening a few weeks ago and I brought
this up to him his response was
Goodfellas is the opening sequence of
Jules in Jim for
two hours I feel in both these sequences
the excitement of having the idea is
expressed in the execution of it and
this is one of my favorite feelings and
movies and something I get often from
both Truffaut and Scorsese my friend Wes
Anderson does this as well there's an
economy and an energy in both we're
introduced to the characters in a very
direct way as I've pointed out that the
the use of the voice-over is is musical
we're told Jules and Jim became friends
it's there's no question about it we're
told I always wanted to be a gangster
it's it's it's not ambiguous the
sequences are almost complete in their
way like short films but they suggest so
much more to come
particularly in Scorsese's movie the
scene you did see within the car
the accordion players not supposed to
come with another five minutes
you know the scene that we see in the
car is mysterious it's thrilling it's
violent it's horrible you know and we
also come back to that scene in a new
context later so it means something to
us differently later but there's also
the thing of being in such they're like
announcing themselves as well that you
feel in such great hands we all have
that experience in movies where III
particularly don't like this in horror
movies where I I don't feel like I'm in
good hands I and I've had that feeling
that anything could happen in this movie
at any time but in the worst way because
I feel taken advantage of I feel
manipulated versus when you're with the
director where you feel like anything
could happen in this movie and I love
that feeling because I will go anywhere
with this person i watching these
sequences feels physical to me I mean
when I when I look at them I I feel like
I'm kind of participating in them it's
the way my father used to be when you
sit on the couch watching Nick games he
would
it's kind of do this like wiggle with
the with the action of the thing and I
feel that way watching these sequences
it's so important too because what the
movies are about is how this visceral
giddy propulsive feeling can't left last
forever it's fleeting in Jules and Jim
it's innocents youth early friendship
early love in Goodfellas it's the rush
of success power I always think this
movie is as much about successes it is
about the mob
it's the party and then what comes
afterwards I'd also just to say also
about the music in Jules and Jim George
delarue's score is such an important
part of it and perhaps we'll talk about
later for marriage story you know Randy
Newman and I listened to a lot of George
Delarue and we looked at a lot of
sequences particularly in Truffaut
movies because of the way he uses it in
Francis ha I used many of these scores
actually used the scores as a kind of
collage to create a similar feeling of
exhilaration the music is big it's
beautiful its romantic its melancholy it
doesn't underscore the scenes or push
for feeling it reacts it almost Springs
out of the movie itself and it plays the
bigness of feeling it gives a sense of
both present and past tense and the
editing the energy I feel like is what
feels so present and in these sequences
but the music makes it feel like past
and there's something very sad about
that I think well why don't we look at
the there's two other clips of openings
that it also like to talk to introduce
and talk about one the first one is from
blue velvet directed by David Lynch and
the second is from movie trouble in
paradise directed by Ernst Lubitsch so
let's play those two clips now please
[Music]
she wore blue Bluebird then was the
night
softer than sappy was the light from
star she wore
[Music]
uber than little bit were I warmer than
May her tender sighs love was
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
because an ID to the venire appearing
contrarians in your s hm
network sorry Kasturi
[Music]
[Music]
yes better much shall we start with
Baron hmm
that's not so easy
beginnings are always difficult yes
[Music]
if Casanova suddenly turned out to be
Romeo having supper with Juliet who
might become Cleopatra
would you start
I would start to be cocktails mm-hmm
very good excellent
[Music]
it must be the most marvelous summer
we may not indeed but it must be nervous
yes in 1986 my friend Bo and I took the
subway into manhattan from brooklyn and
saw blue velvet at the Waverly theater
in Greenwich Village I fabricated this
episode in the squid and the Whale in
that movie Jeff Daniels plays father
chaperones his son in a date to go see
blue velvet because I imagine it would
be uncomfortable and David Lynch was
very kind in lending me the the clip
from blue velvet if you've seen the
movie Isabella Rossellini is naked and
bloody and says he put his disease in me
and then laura dern gives that kind of
indescribable it's almost it's like an
inhalation and an exhalation at the same
time in reaction and I realized recently
actually that that was my first
collaboration with Laura Dern and I
all-time had been thinking that marriage
story was the first time but again it
came when an interviewer asked me about
it and I said no that was Laura Linney
and she said nobody in the blue velvet
anyway says I made there I didn't cry in
this interview
as I said before this was a time when I
was discovering great movies and and and
a lot of directors from the past but I
was also lucky enough to be seeing these
amazing new filmmakers of the moment in
the theater David Lynch Jim Jarmusch
Spike Lee the Coen Brothers Alex Cox
Jane Campion it was a really exciting
time for me to be discovering movies and
you know I think the the sequences I
speak for themselves they're very clear
in certain ways I mean the blue velvet
clip you start with something sort of
familiar and something we've seen a
version of before and then but something
is off and unfamiliar you know and then
of course we go even underneath to this
kind of horrifying disgusting bug life
and it puts you in a mood for what's to
come
although what's to come in blue velvet
is totally unpredictable but it also
expresses how these things live side by
side all of the time in college I took a
screwball comedy class which was 30
comedies of the 30s and 40s which had a
huge impact on me and I saw movies by
Preston Sturges and Howard Hawks and Leo
McCarey and Frank Capra and Ernst
Lubitsch who directed trouble in
paradise and I'd never heard about
trouble in paradise I didn't even I
didn't know who the actors were herbert
marshall who plays the baron miriam
hopkins we see briefly playing the
ukulele is in the gondola k francis old
wonderful actors but not well-known at
least in 1980s and my teacher jim
Stearman because you were in a learning
environment they would point out these
things to you pointed out the genius of
starting with the trash gondola and it
immediately reminded me of Lou velvet at
the time which I had seen already and
you know setting you up right away for
this idea that nothing is exactly what
it seems and beneath the surface a kind
of glassy surface there's a darker
underbelly and that these things are
ever-present and live together always
but at the same time both these movies
are so inviting I mean III all four of
these clips you can't stop watching I
mean if we could we could just watch all
of them and rather than talk I'd
actually rather watch the clips but
Lubitsch's I find it really one of the
best directors I mean ever and I drew
upon a lot from Lubitsch for marriage
story his blocking particularly his
camera movement which you saw some of
there the notion of performance often
his characters are performing in some
way which you learn about that character
to be or not to be another great one
that he did is about the theatre company
in Nazi Germany
there's also often a sense of facade but
mostly his incredible energy so I mean I
picked these clips just as a way of
introduction in a way to sort of talk
about even to get into talking about my
movies because I I feel like those are
really exciting moments and in life when
you start to see connections or
invisible conversations between works of
art from different time periods and
these four were particularly
illuminating for me at the time when I
was growing up and I feel like
unfortunately this happens less
frequently as an adult but when I watch
movies by these filmmakers it brings me
back to that sense of discovery and as a
creative person that's a kind of
headspace I want to be in as much as
possible I'm gonna now show you the
opening of my new movie marriage story
and
afterwards we'll we'll have a
conversation and talk about that movie
and perhaps some others the clip should
be shown now what I love about Nicole
she makes people feel comfortable about
even embarrassing things she really
listens when someone is talking
[Music]
sometimes she listens too much for too
long
[Music]
she's good citizen she always knows the
right thing to do when it comes to
difficult family [ __ ]
I get stuck in my ways and she knows
when to push me and when to leave me
alone she cuts all our hair she's always
inexplicably brewing a cup of tea that
she doesn't trick
[Music]
and it's not easy for her to put away a
sock or close the cabinet or do a dish
but she tries for me
Nicole grew up in LA around actors and
directors and movies and TV and is very
close to her mother Sandra and Cassy her
sister Nicole gives great presents
[Music]
she is a mother who plays really plays
she never steps off plane or says it's
too much and it must be too much some of
the time she's competitive
she's amazing at opening jars because of
her strong arms which I've always found
very sexy
she keeps the fridge over full no one
has ever hungry in our house she can
drive a stick
after that movie all over the girl she
could have stayed in LA and been a movie
star but she gave that up to do theater
with me in New York she's brave she's a
great dancer infectious
she makes me wish I could dance she
always says when she doesn't know
something or hasn't read a book or seen
a film or a play whereas I fake it or
say something like I haven't seen it in
a while my crazy ideas are her favorite
things to figure out how to execute
let's try it rolling but also stand
she's my favorite actress
no that was fantastic
I am I kind of feel like I just want to
listen to you is that permissible well
yes if you ask me the right questions
all time fine let's do that and we might
queue up on you mind we are gonna queue
single clip something right we have
worked um it was fascinating with since
you talked us now put me in mind of a
couple of years I spent teaching English
and at that point in terms of teaching
young children to put one sentence in
front of the other it felt like there
were two ways to do that you could
either teach them grammatical devices
and teach them from the blackboard or
what turned out to be much more
effective you could throw a pile of
fascinating books at that which they
would never have heard of otherwise and
they would make their way through them
and they would become people who were
comfortable and kind of you know joyous
with language it sounds a little bit
like you were doing both at the start of
your career but it was varying towards
the laughter it was varying towards just
bumping into a huge amount of great
films yeah well I had I had the luxury
but also the challenge I would say of
having parents who were cinephiles and
who were would put these movies in front
of me
often movies too or too early like
that's what was saying about Jules and
Jim like I I had seen other
French movies or Italian movies in high
school and I kind of knew I was supposed
to like them I knew they were but I
didn't I just couldn't get there yet and
I always feel like I and this still
happens with certain filmmakers or where
I'll kind of revisit them every few
years with that hope that something is
going to open up and it's not the
American directors - I mean I I you know
like John Ford I'm like I know he's a
great director I'm still waiting to be
to totally enter in not not all of us My
Love My Darling Clementine and the man
who shot Liberty valance but those are
for whatever he's they're more
accessible to me than the searchers
which you know I I know is to be great
but I haven't yet had that feeling of
its greatness and I think you know but
it's exciting when those doing that
happens when those like you say it is
like learning a new language III
éric rohmer I was just in Paris
yesterday so I was trying to say Rohmer
what's that you said for my eighth or
second row man yeah okay yeah yeah no
but éric rohmer in america I I couldn't
I saw a couple of his movies I saw I
think I saw a movie it was in college
and and and I saw a new movie of his
right out of college and I I really
struggled with them and then it was at a
film festival it was a retrospective of
his at the Film Forum in New York and I
decided to give it another chance I
think it was in my late 20s and and and
I it was like a drug I kept going back I
kept and I felt like I was learning a
new language so much so that there was
actually when pulling at the beach which
they're showing them Rell it's sort of
an order and that one's in the 80s and I
when it came I they they had shipped a
print without subtitles and it didn't
matter I felt like I knew I mean I speak
some French but I I I felt like I was so
inside the movies now and his rhythms
and
and and and now he's one of my favorite
filmmakers I wonder is that do you think
just a result getting older and actually
watching more films where is that result
of becoming a filmmaker and actually
knowing that knowing that well from the
inside out I don't know that being a
filmmaker has a lot to do with it
because when a movie connects it
connects viscerally and emotionally it's
not I'm not thinking about usually if
I'm thinking about how a movie was made
it's because I'm not it's not a very
good movie or it's on a movie I'm
responding to I think I mean certainly
age helps experience helps but but I
think it can also just be timing it's
you know you could maybe if you didn't
get it on a Tuesday you could get it on
Wednesday we're here to talk about
script writing specifically so I want to
talk about you as a filmmaker but I mean
in terms of script writing I wonder what
kind of writer you are are you the kind
of writer who is happy with the first
draft when something delights you on
every page and when every scene sings to
you or is it a question of getting to
the point where nothing appalls you and
makes you actually want to shoot
yourself does anybody like the first the
idea of everything delighting me is like
but that's why I keep trying looking for
that moment
well I when I think about script writing
it really is intertwined with directing
for me III an editing to I really do
experience the whole process as one and
I don't and and and I want to talk about
screenwriting but I I'm but I do I I do
find a script that's that isn't a movie
of my own somewhat useless like I don't
think I don't find I don't I don't think
scripts maybe some are somewhere but I
don't think they're complete things
they're by nature potential and and and
you know the
called blueprints or you know and some
directors use them very much as just
guides that you know Robert Altman you
know kind of make an entirely new movie
out of the script he was given I follow
my scripts quite closely I'm
interpreting them as a director but I'm
I'm following we the the lines are the
love the lines and and the scenes of the
scenes but even so on their own I don't
I don't get a lot of delight out of the
Magus and say but but I the way I work
is and I edit the way I pretty much the
way I write which is often I now anyway
I sit down to write when I kind of feel
like I have enough to start and I'm take
a lot of notes and always and and often
there's a few different things that are
sort of going on at once and one thing
kind of announces itself and that when
that wire kind of like electricity goes
through that wire I I try to follow it
but once I have a like scenes or a
beginning or something I tend to I tend
to work forward and go back and revise
and then go a little bit further and
then go back and revise so by the time
I'm done with the script it's close to
being ready which is the same way I I
don't have a rough cut I I start at the
beginning with the my editor Jen lame
and we we cut the movie here we go a
little bit and then we go back and we
revise same thing so that when we're
done it doesn't mean we of course we
make changes throughout but and once you
see it all together it gives you other
ideas but the but it's generally in a
very good shape I don't I don't sort of
throw it up there roughly and then that
I find too disheartening I think it's
funny I remember going to Manhattan for
the first time in the nineties and at
that point I think it was that kind of
Tarantino moment
and you had scripts which were being
sold on the streets they have like
bootleg script it doesn't sound like you
were the kind of person who was seeking
those almost fetishistic I've never seen
a script until I wrote one and it was
before final draft you know or any of
these screenwriting programs and my
first movie kicking and screaming was
the first script I'd ever seen which is
I had to actually write it to see it and
I had so much trouble with the tabs
getting the formatting because it was
before so I just my whole experience
mental memory or emotional memory I
should say of that of that process was
just hitting tab and trying to Center
you know Grover with the line and I I
spent so much time trying to get it to
look like a script that was yeah yeah
and and those and then I looked at some
scripts too just for the formatting I
bought scripts you could buy not not on
the street I didn't know about those but
I I bought published scripts but they
were often or the ones I had were all
kind of transcripts of the finished
movie they didn't look like scripts that
as I've now come to understand them in
terms of looking at the scenes you
played just now and then findings of a
connective tissue to your work it feels
like place is a very obvious one that
actually isn't whether that's Lumberton
there's this sense of place which is
more than just it's never just a
location right ways very much the
essence of the film and that really
feels like something that you've brought
through and your work as well yeah and
yeah and what's interesting about loot
velvet is it's it's very specific when
it's very generalized at the same time
Lumberton or lumbered you know where is
that you know I mean but it seems we all
know where it is but we have no idea
where it is which is amazing yeah place
is a big part of it and I and I'd like
to know the place when I'm writing I
mean obviously I need to know the place
food but I mean I like to even have
visual ideas of the streets the the
locations if I can when I'm writing
because it I feel like it grounds me
it's it for the same reason I often use
real names in my scripts of people I
know not because I'm writing about them
at all
I would never do that but but because
it's immediately a real person to me I
believe it
well like I know that I know who Roger
Greenberg is because I grew up with
Roger greenberg
he wasn't Roger greenberg and greenberg
but he because like also because I
hadn't seen him since I was like 15 but
but um but I had deep affection for him
and for that time in my life and even
though the movie had no literal
connection to that calling him Roger
greenberg made me love him and and and
also made it real to me when you
mentioned Brooklyn in your lecture and
Brooklyn obviously has this pivotal role
and again it's that since Brooklyn is
not just a place it's a source of drama
a source of conflict sometimes you have
that relationship between Manhattan and
Brooklyn which comes up in your work you
know you have a marriage story New York
and LA so it's less Brooklyn specific
although it is Brooklyn but then it's
also Newark and it's the other coast as
well yeah it's also home I think
notions of home and that come up in my
movie I mean even my first movie kicking
and screaming there by design not at
home but there there in college but it's
become a kind of surrogate home that
they don't want to leave and that's sort
of being fixed and associated with a
place and how that can be that can hold
you back or it can propel you forward
you know and you know place and family
and home I mean all these things then
can become versions of each other a
marriage story in New York and LA and
some ways become stand-ins for once the
lawyers use them as arguments in their
divorce it's they've become
representative of the characters
themselves you know and and that's true
but it's also not true
yeah we tend to think of places the kind
of person we don't leave it as you say
this but but Brooklyn Brooklyn - what
you're saying I mean I I have a strong
connection I feel like a lot of what I
I'm doing as a creative person is is is
is a conversation or maybe a sort of
silent conversation with my younger self
who loved movies I mean I think it's why
I was drawn to talk about what I talked
about is that I'm always
talking to that to that person who was
discovering movies for the first time
and so excited about them and so often
I'm drawn to the world of that time as
well he'd been about not squid Noel was
actually that time in my life but the
but even when the movies take place say
in the present it's still in some sort
of cinematic way I'm sort of still
conversing with that boy we're going to
shoot Lee cue up another clip from front
of song and that's a particularly
fascinating thing I want to pick up a
thread really cuz Francis how is a film
which is seen as it's not about you it's
a pain you know it's a different
generation it's a different gender but
I'd be fascinated to know which way
Gretchen you kind of merge on the screen
I mean do you want to say anything about
front is hard before we look at the clip
well it's a good I think it's the
beginning of the movie right so again
well Francis how also was I think even
more directly inspired in my mind anyway
by jules and Jim's opening it and it's
you know it is about friends and it's
also about you know friendship as as
love sort of a love story between
friends and the story of course is is
about that bond but also you know it's
about individuals and a pair at the same
time which marriage story is to but you
know you can show the clip and you sort
of see how I was sort of you know
introducing again the sort of language
of the movie that that you were gonna
later see absolutely well let's look at
this clip from
[Music]
I tried to make a Kitano fit to be more
of a scram this is interesting to praise
a work of literature by calling it
sincere is now at best a way of saying
that our intellectual
[Music]
I wouldn't even get a dog you say that
just because they're
[Music]
I'll be stupid I should sleep in my own
bed
why because I bought it
stay take off your socks not in a while
like I just took the the world premiere
of Francis I was at the Telluride Film
Festival which is a amazing festival we
were just we were there with marriage
story I loved it but we were premiering
the movie and no one knew we'd even made
the movie because we kind of made it
sort of under the radar
and so it was very exciting you know
here it goes and there was some the
movie began and there was music and
picture but I knew because there's also
dot like a low dialogue soundtrack you
know ambient track underneath that
wasn't playing and and but there was no
way that anyone who didn't know the
movie would know so I turned to the
person the you know friendly person with
the headset who was next to me in case
there was a problem until they know you
got to turn it off you gotta turn it and
just not it takes the mystery and drama
out of showing a movie when you're like
we're to have to restart and so they
stopped the movie sort of partly way in
and then then they a few minutes and
then they show it again it's the same
problem again and then so then they
stopped it again and you're really
losing the momentum of your worldwide
premiere but I did have to explain to
people that the movie is actually in
black and white yeah because at that
point I think they were all like good
it's also the colours off
so third time lucky did it did it the
third time it played as it was supposed
to of course in my imagination there was
somebody like oh you know plugging in
the thing but really you know that thing
in the movie is really like the things
it's not but I'm sure was I'm sure was
more sophisticated than that but it's
such a beautiful scene though because it
feels so haphazard and it feels so
random it's like a sort of box of
snapshots that you've just stumbled upon
and you realize by the end of it you
have you've given us so much information
information is very unsexy word but it's
also vitally important and it's movie
storytelling and it's this incredibly
again I mean it's a high price it's very
functional thing you know you talk about
oh well that's interesting I mean it's
again going to the clips that we looked
at in the beginning which are I mean
they're poetry but they're also they're
just as you say they're absolutely
functional they really just tell the
story I mean they they I mean in that
ernst lubitsch clip you learn so much so
quickly and you get the trash gondola so
it's just like man you know it's like
amazing and it's you know and and as I
was thinking about Goodfellas and jewels
and chim they actually just tell you
exactly what you need to know I mean we
don't use voice over here but but we did
because we didn't need it and it wasn't
the style at the movie but the the but
yeah and then of course I'm even
watching it now looking at them fighting
in the beginning and it's a play fight
but they're fighting and I'm like that
that of course is sort of what the
movies about to you know but I mean this
movie was in some ways like it was as I
was making it was the movie I needed to
make and it but it almost didn't know it
I wanted to make a movie in a different
way than I had before and in a sense I
felt like I wanted to make the first
film I had my first film all over again
or a first film I never did make and and
I was also exploring working digitally
for the first time which I mean I've
since gone back to film marriage story
is shot on film meyerwitz stories before
it was shot on film but
I wanted to to shoot with a very small
crew and kind of not the sort of notion
of like we don't need to tell anybody
what why do you I've always have to like
tell everyone you're making let's just
go make something you know if you know
we the conversation we're having right
now could be in the movie if we were
recording it and filming it so let's
just do that and Greta and I wrote the
script but it really did I think also
shooting in black and white sort of
going to your sense of place I was
shooting in New York again I had shot
Greenberg in LA before so I was coming
back to New York and I think seeing New
York with kind of fresh eyes literally
in a different with no color and in a
different way and in a different medium
with digital sort of it
it freed other things up even in the
storytelling and in the and and I love
that about making movies because it's of
what I was saying too about the things
you know and the things you don't and if
you I find more and more if you focus on
the storytelling the really sort of
wouldn't do you think the functionality
of things then you'll back into some
more magical or or or you know things
that can be misconstrued as profound I
mean was the writing process a kind of
question of relearning as well because
filmmaking is collaboration of course
but I mean writing at least at first
draft stage isn't I mean writing to
writing solo you know you're there you
are for that moment the executive but
he'll collaborating with greater from
the from the fluid word go with the
script I mean how much we change did
that represent for you well I had
collaborated with Wes Anderson on the
movies that he directed but this was the
first time I collaborated with somebody
where I was directing it and yeah it was
it was but it's less lonely for sure and
what's nice about it is it is about
conversation although Greta and I
weren't in the same place very often
when we wrote Frances ah we were a lot
of it was done
individually and then emailed back and
forth and then we would revise each
other's and then I would sort of collect
this bigger script as a whole and we
would and start putting it together it's
funny because it is I mean I get us the
question a lot but you know about
autobiography and my movies and the one
I get asked the least is I mean you you
were alluding to this I think in your
introduction to it the the one I get
asked the least about is Frances ha
because people don't see me as a 27 year
old female but it actually I think a lot
about there's a lot of how I you know I
went through a period after I made I
made two movies when I was quite young
I've made kicking and screaming when I
was 24 25 and then movie mr. jealousy
when I was 27 and then I didn't make
another movie till I was 34 or something
at 34 35 with squid in the whale and
that period for me was a period of real
struggle and in my sort of conscious
mind I was I was just trying to get
another movie made I was writing things
trying to get another movie made what I
was doing unconsciously was growing up
and and I felt very much like I mean
Francis talks at some point someone says
what do you do and she goes well it's
hard to describe and they say why she
was because I don't really do it and I
felt that way I'd made two movies but I
didn't feel like I could call myself a
filmmaker because I wasn't doing it and
I wanted to do it again but I wasn't
doing it and it was a it was a very hard
time and and I i emotionally reflected a
lot on that time from from my point of
view it means so much and Greta's in the
movie too obviously but um you know in
that sort of
what I guess they call quarter life
crisis it's no it's just fascinating
here you talk is also I mean I think
people do think of Frances heart as as
greatest film but from what you're
saying it almost feels as if there's a
timeless quality both to the change in
Brooklyn and also to you know Greta at
27 then there is still part of you at 27
a little further down the line and it's
so culturally specific it's about you
know while we're young is the same thing
that happens they're very specific about
about Brooklyn now although with Francis
I feel like it is culturally specific
you're right but it is part of the
choice to do it in black and white was
to put it out of time - and while we're
young is more I feel like in time in
time it culturally-specific and it's and
and maybe even has some limitations
because of that Francis I do feel like
it and also the use of the music it is
all George Delarue music in there's some
other songs that we've just a Paul
McCartney there's David Bowie it's
modern love that she runs - but it it
was all by design - kind of I felt in a
way to sort of to honor her you know
then that you had this you know in a
certain sense and ordinary life and I
but for all of us living it it's
extraordinary and I wanted the movie to
kind of to react in kind and and give
back to her and that's what that music
does we've got another clip of marriage
story to look at but I wonder just
before we play it because it speaks to
this point I mean did the character of
Francis and also working with Greta did
it improve you as a writer yeah
absolutely
I mean if for no other reason I was just
trying to impress her hi I am she would
send me scenes and I'd be low boy this
is so good it was so it was like so
exciting you know to the point that you
know you just like if I knew maybe a
scene was coming I would just be like
refreshing email hoping the
would come through yeah it it would
always I was always made me feel good if
she liked liked what I sent her and and
were laughed at a thing or something
like that and but it so certainly on
those movies but it I think it did I
know it has I've improved I've improved
as a human being because of her but I've
been proved as a as a writer director at
least in my eyes from watching her from
working with her and watching her and
watching her movies now - let's pick up
this right off to this next clip from my
read story we can accept an imperfect
dad let's face it the idea of a good
father was only invented like 30 years
ago before that fathers were expected to
be silent and absent and unreliable and
selfish and we can all say we want them
to be different some basic level we
accept them we love them for their
fallibilities but people absolutely
don't accept those same failings and
mothers we don't accept it structurally
and we don't accept it spiritually
because the basis of our judeo-christian
whatever is Mary Mother of Jesus and
she's perfect she's a virgin
who gives birth unwaveringly supports
her child and holds his dead body when
he's gone and the dad isn't there he
didn't even do the [ __ ] God is in
heaven God is the father and God didn't
show up so you have to be perfect and
Charlie can be a [ __ ] and it doesn't
matter you will always be held to a
different higher standard and it's
[ __ ] up but that is the way it is said
the screenplay clip well let's just pick
up the conversation because I think it's
worth saying actually it's interesting
you've you applauded then I mean I think
when the film's been on the festival
circuit for the last few months I mean
there has been quite a lot of
spontaneous applause at that scene in
particular I mean I wonder do you feel
like you could have written that without
having co-written front is half of us
probably not I mean III also without
knowing Laura was playing it III a lot
of the impetus for that scene came from
talking to Laura because I Laura and
Adam and Scarlett I'd had I involved in
the movie even before I was writing it
and one thing that I was talking to
Laura about in playing this character
was turbulence in the movie it's a
divorce lawyer and was and we were
talking about it even from an actor's
perspective of like what what what what
got her into this job in the first place
what is what is you know you it wasn't
always you know Machiavellian or you
know or you know gee you know she's
obviously very good at working within
the system and the system is Kafkaesque
and in a way not to quote the squid in
the whale but it so was the sort of
notion if that she got into it to
crusade for people and for women in
particular and so that was kind of the
thought like and I thought well then we
should hear that that should come
forward and working on that scene with
Laura was amazing too because there were
so many ways to envision it like and I
would you know just say you know what
like why don't you say it now like
you're having these ideas more for the
first time why don't you say it now like
it's prepared why don't you try it now
like you get angrier as you tell it you
know and one is that it's almost
cathartic as you know and then and she
could just dial it in and out and and so
it was it was you know that's just one
of those sort of fun days at work but
Greta is very much in that too I mean I
mean I think in in in writing at to it
was like I would talk to her about it as
well and throughout this whole movie and
and you know I mean we were very much
involved in each other's work even the
ones that were not working on you know
officially together we're always very
involved in each other's work in terms
of you
with actors how much of a joy is it for
you to almost just in a second
relinquish control to them because
obviously you can control what's on the
page but then once once it's with an
actor it can't help it become something
different I mean is that a pleasure for
you yeah absolutely
and I and I actually find that I mean in
some ways working with actors is not
dissimilar to what I was saying about
writing in that if you get the basics
right you know again the storytelling
the efficiency the you know not the the
the a sequence other things start to
reveal themselves in in the work and
suddenly you see oh that's in there -
well now I can detour a little here
because I've got this you've got the
framework you have the structure I can
now do this little aside and this little
thing here and and maybe break like I
said break a rule here and I find that
that's for me and in a way the I mean
Elia Kazan always talked about being a
prop but you know people say you know
talk about what a good director he was
with actors he said I'm a prop director
you know I come up with good props for
them and things for them to do and that
gives them ideas and it opens them up
and I and I and I know what he means I
mean I think giving them a framework and
a structure you know all these scenes
are are very blocked out and we we have
it really down to every little moment
and the dialogue is all precise but then
just as you say then they I feel like it
gives them all the freedom in the world
to to be present to just be in the you
know to find the truth of what's going
on and find their truth and and working
with actors like this - who are alive -
every everything that's different in the
moment and everything different that
they give if they're in a scene with
somebody else even if they're off camera
you know they'll change based on the
reaction that they're getting you know
Adam driver and
the movies you you know will you know
he'll say we'll do a few takes and I'll
be feeling pretty good and then he'll
say you know I'm gonna try it not
crossing my legs this time and I know to
him that means something else is gonna
happen yeah it's because he's changing
his reality and changing his physical
posture it's it's all you know he's so
he's so aware of how all of these things
factor into performance and and I tried
to give actors as much of that as I can
or that I think of you know and I might
say to an actor maybe don't cross your
legs or maybe stand up this time because
I feel like you know it'll change
something you know and that's exciting
and and I do relate it to writing in
that way no one's sadder than I have to
do this but we're going we're out of
time we're going to have to leave it in
the police Noah Baumbach thanks
[Applause]
[Music]